[Music]
if you are interested in stories with
happy endings that story is streaming
elsewhere I would advise all our viewers
to watch something more pleasant instead
I am Count Olaf your new Guardian where
are your pants now we're orphans put
them to work in the mill mess economy
children are lucky to have a job at all
your first impression of me may be that
I am a terrible person
when are we going to eat but you haven't
the faintest idea you have to understand
he had a very terrible childhood don't
look so down having a very terrible
childhood right now okay our parents are
never coming back we're all frightened
Klaus mother and father they made me
promise to always look after you let me
keep my promise
[Music]
you're finally safe now children just as
your parents wanted find your aunt
Josefina
she can tell you everything you need to
know do you live with her aunt Josephine
I am your aunt Josephine good morning
I am stefano his afternoon and your
Count Olaf the only reason my car Olaf
hasn't owned you limb from limb is
because he hasn't gotten a hold of your
fortune
you'll never get away with this
therefore she will be mine
carpe diem seize the children cheese
today I said day
[Music]
those colliding the operations over when
I keep it up okay only one survives